fine at booktv.org
yeah
hi all
good afternoon
it's good to have you here thanks for
coming in
this is another this is now discussion
and that is a production of the kepler's
literary foundation i'm angie coiro and
i'm a member of the events team here at
kepler's
keplers.org keplers.com two different
animals keplers.org is the nonprofit
foundation that works to bring
literature and enlightenment and
enhancement of life to everyone here and
out to the schools and in various other
venues across the uh the peninsula so
thank you for all your support just by
virtue of being here by virtue of being
the audience you are supporting klf and
thank you for that i i have to ask
is it someone in the audience who has
the bumper sticker downstairs i work and
pay taxes so the wealthy don't have to
yeah
you are starting us off on a very good
note
so uh i'm going to ask you to please
turn down your cell phones you don't
have to turn them off in fact if you'd
like to tweet we are at kepler's
and it is time to introduce our guest
we're going to start doing that with a
quick review of some headlines
purdue pharma is the company that
produces oxycontin and that is a key
player in our opioid price crisis in
fact
purdue pharma is being sued by 1 000
different entities cities towns
individuals for their contribution to
our opioid crisis well the billionaire
ex-president of purdue pharma is now
working to profit on the other side of
that mess he is helping to patent a
formula that will help wean people off
oxycontin
another headline some 2000 prison
inmates were paid a dollar an hour to
fight the california wildfires now the
san francisco chronicle has been
covering the construction of a playhouse
by unpaid san quentin prisoners for a
high-ranking prison executive who now is
reportedly out of a job
so there are a lot of news stories that
you can read that might strike new
chords with you once you read america
the farewell tour in one chapter after
another chris hedges documents the ills
that are taking the country down hate
heroin
sadism magical thinking those are just a
few
then he shows us how to build it back up
but he doesn't sugarcoat that it's going
to be hard he says and many of us will
fall by the wayside if we choose to do
that work and he doesn't want us to go
into that blind chris hedges is a
journalist a columnist a tv show host
and a presbyterian minister he teaches
in prison his writing has won multiple
awards including a shared pulitzer prize
for the new york times where he worked
for 15 years as a foreign correspondent
america the farewell tour is his 14th
book please welcome chris hedges
thank you you're welcome while we get
chris miked up i want to tell you that
you have some white note cards they are
either in your hands or you're sitting
on them at this point
those are um for you to ask questions
and make some comments for us
i would ask that you keep them concise
and well written and on point and during
our one hour discussion we'll get to as
many of those questions and comments as
we can the way those get up here is
after you write them out hold them up
andrew or jean will pick those up and
get them on up to me so we'll kind of
wrap them in as we go along and we're
going to test your mic how okay how's
that
oh you got to do more than that
[Laughter]
perfection of a kind was what he was
after and the poetry invented was very
easy to understand auden how's that
and scott says thumbs up
let's dive in
i have to tell you
reading the book
i got about two chapters in
and i
found it so relentless and i knew
there'd be more hope in the end i
cheated ahead to the last chapter
and knowing that there's stuff we can do
knowing that everything isn't all over i
found it easier to go back and read the
rest
so i just wonder about if you knew that
the
the tone can be intimidating
well i think on purpose because
i i don't share
the american culture's mania for hope
and i think that comes out of spending
two decades as a war correspondent we
made a very cold
calculated assessment
of what the weapons systems were around
us and we responded we also understood
that so many of our victories were purik
uh during the war i covered the war in
el salvador for five years
we would often the roads would be
blocked after the salvadoran military
committed a massacre we would have to
walk in often at great danger this was
also true uh especially during the war
in kosovo
indeed the serb snipers often fired on
the journalists who walked in
and there was
a sense
or a feeling of euphoria when we were
able to document the atrocities that
these atrocities that they had sought to
hide from public view
these lives that they had extinguished
and hoped would never be recorded
i was able to put on the front page of
the new york times but it didn't mean
that i wasn't going to wake up tomorrow
and have to do it all over again indeed
that usually was the pattern
coupled with the fact
that that work was very dangerous i mean
many of the
people i worked with the photographers
and war reporters
over those two decades including my
closest friend uh kurt shork are are
dead they didn't make it
and i i think that that that that
baseline and it comes somewhat out of my
education
as a seminarian steeped in calvin and
niebuhr and i i not only have a dark
view of humanity i have a tragic view of
life
um which is very much at odds with the
obsessive positive thinking of a
consumer society and a commercial
culture
but i think it actually
gives you a kind of armor
to cope
with what's happening
and just from climate
change alone
things are very bleak and dangerous
and
i i think the greatest or perhaps
hardest existential crisis
of our time is to
grasp
reality and yet
resist anyway um but i i just am not
willing and i don't think it's
beneficial to give people exits
from how bleak it is both in terms of
what we're doing to the biosphere
uh and this concentration of
wealth in the hands of
the global elite
uh
where it's not and it's of course not
just economic ramifications 70 percent
of this country
is living paycheck to paycheck
um
but of course it has political
consequences as carl boyani writes in
the great transformation which is his
book on the nature of unfettered
unregulated capitalism
he said that you create a mafia economy
but eventually you create a mafia
political system which is of course what
the trump white house is
i of course i'm going to get into the
guts of the book but i'm i'm taking
the way the world has informed your view
of it
and the fact that you're a father
and i i wonder how you have those two
things together that the world is bleak
and let's not do artificial hope
so
what is it that you offer your children
to
let them get up in the morning
well i have younger children and older
children i'm pretty frank with the older
children and and
uh
the the younger children are certainly
aware of climate change
um
but one doesn't pummel a 10 year old
right with uh
you know the the uh
details of the
melting of the polar ice caps and the
consequences of
going beyond two percent
celsius and feedback loops and um
but i i'm very worried and and i'm i'm
increasingly worried in a culture
that unplugs itself from the real world
uh and i and i see within our commercial
media
uh
uh a kind of
walking away from responsible journalism
for
endless carnival endless burlesque which
is what cnn is
i mean i come out of the old newspaper
world and the idea that
uh repeated reports or interviews with a
former porn star and a lawyer who wants
to run for president and a former
reality television
star who was
in the white i mean this is this is uh
it's just pt barnum all the time
uh and there are extremely serious
things happening around us
uh including the debacles that we are
engaged in in the middle east 17 years
of futile and endless war that just go
unspoken uh
we don't we don't even have a rational
discussion
in the mainstream uh
about the nature of corporate capitalism
and how it works uh and so
um
you know as soon as you say corporate
capitalism i think there's a large part
of the
populists who just said
you know
crazy liberal old hippie whatever
i think i think that the very
phraseologist i'm neither a liberal or a
hippie
but that's the impression that's i think
that's an honest
when people say you know corporate
capitalism i don't know if you say
corporate capitalism to the the farm
families in the town in upstate new york
where i grew up whose farms have
all been foreclosed upon and who have
suffered a rash of suicides and
deep economic distress they know very
well what corporate capitalism is if you
go to anderson indiana as i do in this
book and you talk to the old uaw workers
who've been in the gm plants that are
now down in monterey mexico paying
mexican workers three dollars an hour
without benefits
uh and their town has become a wasteland
like all de-industrialized
former manufacturing centers in the
united states they get corporate
capitalism uh i i i think the victims
get it
well let's let's start there let's start
with anderson and it's emblematic of any
number of cities sure
it used to be based in
factory work or you know um
that kind of everybody goes to work
together there's a union right um it's a
company town completely anderson was
yeah and when the company goes away
you're left with people who essentially
have nothing
these are some that and the lace factory
that went out you know which we can talk
about opened up scranton
and other cities scranton pennsylvania
when you talk to the people in those
towns
what do they say about having lost and
i'm picking a point to start on what do
they see about having lost their unions
that they might have expected to protect
them from all this
well once you pass nafta
you
open the door for gm to do what they did
which is to move their plants overseas
right um that had nothing to do with the
unions
um i mean the the corporate managers
will often seek to blame the unions
uh because
uh they were paying union workers twenty
five thirty dollars an hour
and providing benefits god forbid yeah
and a pension
and you could
support a family on one salary
and you could send your kids to college
and you could own a home
and they they will argue quite correctly
that of course it's
far cheaper for them to produce
vehicles in monterey
um but that's not the fault of the union
i mean the compensation packages for
these corporate executives
has reached utterly obscene proportions
uh in the 1950s i think the ratio was
thirty to one or fifty to one in terms
of ceo worker
now it's in the hundreds 500 600
uh to one
uh
and
so that the the the staggering income
inequality which is the worst
in american history it is now
outstripped
the so-called gilded age
has not just economic consequences
but political consequences
as every political theorist going back
to aristotle understood
and and it it i and i i go back to the
former yugoslavia i was the balkan
bureau chief for the new york times
the economic collapse of yugoslavia
vomited up these
political monstrosities like radovan
karitic slobodan milosevic franio tujman
uh who like trump
ridiculed in this with the same kind of
vulgarity
and also i should mention the same
incitement to violence and the same
racism
they
ridiculed an established elite that was
ineffectual
in terms of dealing with the legitimate
grievances and suffering
of the mass of the population
and that that is that was trump's
success
in that however crude and
and repugnant he was and is
he nevertheless
expressed
a rage and i would say a legitimate rage
on the part of in particular the white
working class
towards the elites like the jeb bush's
or the
bill and hillary clinton's
who betrayed them
uh and uh and they did betray them why
did that message resonate when we're
talking about a guy with whom you know
everything is gilded everything you know
everything is very high-end everything
is all about you know this is very i
wouldn't say it high-end and say it's
tacky this okay it's very tacky yes it
is tacky but i guess i'm i'm trying to
understand why a messenger like that is
someone you would be you would believe
about the week because
in in moments of political distress this
opens the door for demagogues and con
artists
and all of those political figures i
just named in yugoslavia were demagogues
and con artists
they tell people what they want to hear
um
the the the power of trump as matt taibi
i think is pointed out correctly is that
reality for him is delivered through a
television screen
and in that sense he's completely
connected with unfortunately a large
percentage of the american public
for whom the television screen is the
lens
by which they interpret and understand
the world around them
so
trump
like all celebrities
has a manufactured personality we know
from his business record that he was
pretty much of a disaster as a business
person a multiple bankruptcies
he defrauded his investors
he
refused to pay his contractors
especially in atlantic city many of whom
went bankrupt
and so he goes on a reality television
show and they create this fictional
persona of him as this business
titan
uh and then he uses this fictional
persona
to sell himself
to the presidency
but all of this comes through television
all of this comes through
make believe
and with the ability to deliver these
electronic
hallucinations in 24-hour streams and
hand-held devices we are as
uh i think it was
uh neil gabler wrote probably the most
illusioned society on the planet
because all of this is constructed it's
not real
it it's interesting to me that we're
already getting a slew of questions
about how to talk to people with whom
you don't have for example i remember
during the election there was a slew of
people who said how can you look at
trump and not get his business record
how can you look and not get his
inauthenticity
and that's to me where the divide really
started making itself evident
betw between the people who could have
benefited by looking at the corporate
underpinnings of everything that was
happening instead
you had trump and we didn't understand
why they didn't look at trump the way
we did a lot of people are asking about
how you talk to someone who's that far
apart from well i would i would say that
those who
have are part of
the
in particular white elite who live in
places like menlo park have the luxury
of uh dismissing trump
but when you're desperate
when the established elites of the two
main political parties have lied to you
successively over years
and betrayed you
and destroyed your family and destroyed
your community and extinguished your
hope and thrust you into despair the
highest i write about suicide in the
book the highest rates of suicide in the
united states are middle-aged white men
[Music]
so uh the the the lies of the
uh republican and democratic party
establishment were slicker
were more carefully packaged were
delivered in a tone of reasonableness
um
and the lies of a trump are crude and
vulgar
uh
but
there is a desperation i mean this is
you know i as you know i traveled all
over the country for this from
utah to scranton to you know
at one point actually literally
seen around a bonfire in upstate new
york
near binghamton with white hate groups
praying
that that none of them would google me
[Laughter]
which didn't always work because you had
your contact information exposed you've
been attacked from a lot of angles you
know people talking about
whether you were
um engaging in plagiarism i mean there
are a lot of persons well let's just if
you want to bring that up i mean the
person who made that charge is the head
of anarchists for trump well that's what
i'm saying is that you were
i mean you can find anything you want on
the internet i understood but that's
part of what i'm saying is that if you
have someone who is speaking something
that they don't want to hear they being
anyone that you're that you're
exposing
then there are ways to go after you
personally right well disturb the
message sure and and the new york times
just reviewed this novel and the whole
column is about me and uh largely
and not at all about the novel and they
did to me just what the new yorker did
to glenn greenwald which is to paint you
as messianic and angry
[Music]
and and that becomes a way to
marginalize if not delegitimize what it
is you're writing about and i would just
for the record i admire glenn quite a
bit so
that's that's standard and
uh i i think that part of the reason
that a an establishment liberal
organization like the new yorker goes
after someone like greenwald or
would go after someone like me is
because we call out the
hypocrisy of the liberal class
and
you end up not having many friends at
all
when you are critiquing
the establishment whether the
establishment the establishment uh
the democratic or the republican
establishment and i
you know i'm i'm quite fierce on both
so
um that you know inevitably makes you a
very lonely isolated and often
uh uh
reviled figure but that's the price of
at least from my perspective that's the
price of trying to be as honest
as you can and in that sense you know
uh
you know i i went to harvard divinity
school but i lived in a housing project
in roxbury for two and a half years uh
actually across the street from the
mission main mission extension housing
project and ran a church there and i
always say that uh the two and a half
years i lived in roxbury has learned
when i learned to really hate liberals
all of those people at harvard who liked
the poor but didn't like the smell of
the poor who sat around talking about
empowering people they never met so
um this which going back to your earlier
question this knee-jerk response that
you're a liberal uh or
you know that that that just becomes a
way
to
attach
a particular
label in this case completely incorrect
a particular label to you
uh and then use that label to
uh essentially shut down what it is you
have to say and that's a very standard
technique i mean when i denounced the
war in iraq uh for which i had a clash
with my then employer the new york times
um the wall street journal ran an
editorial calling me a liberal pacifist
well i'm not a pacifist i was in
sarajevo during the war
when we were being hit with two thousand
shells a day
and
i like everyone else in sarajevo
understood that if you did not man the
trench system it was literally a trench
system around the city
the serbs would break through and
slaughter
a third of the population and push the
rest into displacement in refugee camps
uh and we that wasn't conjecture that's
what they did in the drina valley it's
what they did in buchavar
it doesn't save you from the poison of
violence but i mean this was just a way
to and i mean i'd also been the middle
east bureau chief for the new york times
uh for sev and speak arabic and was
there seven years these were informed
decisions but by using those labels
it becomes a way to dismiss
what it is you have to say
that's in line with one of our audience
questions is there ever a place or
necessity for violence even to protect
our children from disastrous leadership
um there are moments when uh there are
forces and the serb forces surrounding
sorry would be a good example of that
where those forces seek the annihilation
of
of potentially your family and yourself
and um
you are faced with that awful choice of
having to pick up a weapon
and i my first book war is a force that
gives us meaning
is an attempt to
explain the culture of war
and
the danger of
using violence i mean the people who
first organized the defenses in sarajevo
uh were largely came out of the criminal
class they were people who had access to
weapons and a pension for violence and
when they weren't holding back
the serbs
they were looting
the apartments of the ethnic serbs who
had remained behind and in some cases
not only stealing everything they had
but killing them um that's the the the
dark
world you
are sucked into once you
employ
violence even in a supposedly just
cause
um
but yes i mean i i covered the war in el
salvador uh in there were peaceful huge
peaceful marches in san salvador the
capital and
the uh military
and the police set up machine guns on
the roofs and fired into the crowds well
that made peaceful
resistance impossible and we got this
tragic civil war
but it's always the oppressor who
determines the
response
and when the oppressor or those in power
refuse over a long period of time
to
to heed the cries of the oppressed
and they use harsher and harsher forms
of control then they provoke counter
violence
let's go into some of the areas of
escape and decay that you look at and
i'm picking out some of the chapter
headings to
give us an entree
heroin work sadism hate gambling and
then of course chapter seven last
chapter we'll talk about freedom
heroin is an interesting one because it
starts out as something of an escape
and then of course once you're addicted
there you are we've seen so much death
deaths have almost doubled
since 2006
and
i think that it might be
a surprise to some people to look at
that and see corporate underpinnings
here can you explain how corporations
are there and in fact if you'd like to
respond to that story i mentioned
about what the purdue pharma exec is
doing now which is well this is the
sackler family who are the largest drug
pushers in the country and have made
billions off of
addicting
hundreds of thousands if not a few
million americans
by pushing
heroin derivatives oxycodone
and setting up
doctor doctors are complicit and setting
up pill mills
where do these pill mills where are they
set up well they're not set up in menlo
park and they're not set up in princeton
where i live
uh they are set up in places
that uh
are suffering deep economic dislocation
and despair of course
um southern west virginia
um
and
uh these
pills were given i mean you had a back
ache suddenly you got a heroin
derivative you've got oxycontin
percocet and
they're highly addictive
uh and they're expensive and eventually
you turn to heroin because it's cheap
six dollars a bag
and the bags are now often laced with
fentanyl
uh and they kill you
um
so
uh
which oddly makes the heroin more
attractive to some of the consumers
if you have a death from fentanyl then
you have a group of addicts you're going
to know i wrote about in the book yeah
which surprised me like
they all
uh it's death by marketing so somebody
dies of an overdose and everybody wants
that these bags have names you know
i don't know red star or something so
they all want it because i mean it's
just kind of nuts but it shows you how
perverse that world is and heroin uh
there's a book dreamland uh forget the
author it's quite good which i read um
and in there he writes about how that
arrow the molecules of hair it doesn't
it can't wash it out of your body so a
year later you can uh feel as if you're
dope sick even though you've been clean
for a year
it's a really pernicious drug
um and that's what makes what the
sackler family did through purdue pharma
so criminal
there's an interesting point you make
about that is when rats get an extra
dose of
opioids they increase their play with
each other they even tickle each other
when rodents are allowed to socialize
free freely rather than remain isolated
in steel cages they voluntarily avoid
the opiate-laden bottle hanging from the
bars of their cage they've already got
enough yeah how what does that tell us
about the humans well it tells us that
our you know and the model for this book
is really durkheim's study of suicide
the breakdown of social bonds durkheim
found led to
a desire for self-annihilation uh and as
durkheim understood that lust to commit
death
is at its core about self-annihilation
so you see it in these nihilistic
mass shootings i write about dylann roof
of course and quote because dylann roof
left a written record
um
so
i mean it's it's a i think a very
revealing study for what's happened the
social decay
uh what durkheim calls the anime
uh that has propelled people into
activities that are
deeply self-destructive so the book is
about those pathologies i mean gambling
for instance and i didn't know a lot
about it
um until uh i spent time in the trump
taj mahal before trump even announced he
was going to be president uh and and and
it was it had gone through several
bankruptcies
uh there were rodents literally running
across the dining room floors uh you
went into the bathrooms and they had
plastic bags over the urinals of the
toilets saying out of order the
the tiles were falling off the there was
mold in the ceiling many of the rooms
had been mothballed it was kind of a
wonderful image for what he's going to
do to the country
um
and
uh
and what was and and uh schooled a
professor at nyu wrote addicted by
design a very fine book where she worked
with the industry about how
eighty percent of gambling is done on
slots and these slots replicate the kind
of zombie like state
that one gets when they take
uh a depressant like heroin um
people it's called time on device and
the and the way they monitor these
people and many of the tactics in terms
of uh building profiles uh that now the
security and surveillance state
and thank you google and facebook i
should say for complicit in this uh
build on about us were pioneered within
the
casino industry because they wanted to i
mean they did they they built
projections as to how
much addicted gamblers would actually
spend
during their lifetimes um
you know they could trace when they
would get frustrated they would show up
and give them free coupons while they're
sitting at that slot machine
uh to
to keep them um and and
uh
uh gambling addicts actually have the
highest rates of attempted suicide or
suicide of any
addiction so but but it replicates the
many other
forms of addiction which are really
about
uh
unplugging yourself from
uh
from the world around you because
reality has become so difficult to bear
there was only one place in the book
that i was reading that i i i felt in it
a strong disagreement with you when you
were talking about prostitution and you
interviewed some women who are activist
against prostitution he also interviewed
some women who were frankly victimized
by prostitution the only thing that rang
wrong to me
is the dismissing of women who say
that they are voluntarily making a
living and okay with being
in prostitution with okay with being
paid for sex
and the difficulty i had with that
was there was well the women who are
saying that don't realize they've been
victimized they don't realize that
psychology that's going on and i feel
women are told an awful lot that they're
wrong about the truth they express about
themselves
that when they state their reality
someone said well if you were if you
were more keyed in you understand that
what you're saying isn't true that was
the only thing that hit me wrong
well
first of all statistically we know that
most of the women who engage in and i'm
actually writing about a very extreme
form of prostitution i'm writing about
the bdsm community
out of kink.com in san francisco which
is torture i mean there's just no other
way around it i took classes
at uh king.com
uh sitting in a basement room with a
bunch of doms you know
kind of dweeby guys dressed in black
and we know statistically that a huge
percentage of these women were sexually
abused often as children
i've interviewed enough of them and i my
longest chapter in empire of illusion is
on the porn industry to know that it was
uh economic
uh distress
that pushed them
uh into this industry also it's uh the
ptsd when i first started interviewing
women who had been in the porn industry
i remember the first interview i did and
they started speaking i instantly
recognized the ptsd that i carried from
20 years of war
so um
that's the first point the second point
is that the vast majority of women who
are are prostituted
uh are it's not uh what was that movie
pretty woman with juilliard it's not
like that right there they're
usually women of color
uh and if you go to europe they're all
uh women of color or women from eastern
europe who are
trafficked
and
um
i
i do break with the left i mean you talk
about being a liberal i mean this is not
a liberal belief but it's one that i
hold actually
that
um
we have to
decriminalize
the act of prostitution i.e the women
are not the criminals uh but the
traffickers and the
uh
the pimps and you know these figures are
should be criminals
and customers and john so i think that's
a very rational model i think it's
compassionate to the women but the point
is that we should be building a society
whereby that is not the only economic
alternative a woman has and as you know
i quote rachel moran
who was a prostituted woman in ireland
for many years
and she's quite graphic about describing
having sex with repugnant men who she
doesn't want to have and she calls up
being raped for a living
and
yes there are very vocal voices in the
quote-unquote sex industry
but i would encourage people to look at
where the money is coming from
that funds that industry
most of the women that i sought out who
had been in the prostitution industry or
in the porn industry
they don't want to talk
you know they suffer the same kind of
trauma well it's not the same but a
similar form of trauma that those of us
who come out of war suffered
uh and so
uh i i would also add you know as a war
correspondent the only thing that wars
produce in greater number than corpses
are prostitutes um these are uh widows
women uh
girls in refugee camps i mean
prostitution was endemic in every war
that i covered
um
and it gets into the
commodification of human beings you know
that that of course the natural world is
a commodity that we're destroying but
also under corporate capitalism human
beings are commodities that we exploit
uh and as somebody who sees with
intrinsically in every form of life
uh
and not just human life
the sacred um i i this is just something
i can't i can't support
let's move over to the alt-right and the
alt light
and how one serves essentially as an
entree to the other
right so
trump is kind of the alt-light
uh you know there's good people on both
sides
but it funnels people into the alt-right
which is kind of
that spectral figure of stephen miller
um in the white house uh
so
it it
normalizes and maybe legitimizes
racism
as we said before incitement to violence
uh it has the
effect of demonizing
um
the vulnerable
and in proto-fascist or fascist
societies it's the vulnerable who pay
i mean the whole idea that 11 million
undocumented workers most of whom are
from mexico and central america
are at fault for the economic
decline of the united states as patently
absurd
but as things devolve and we are headed
for another economic crisis the new york
times four or five days got a very
chilling editorial that said this and
they had an article
a week ago about how the fracking
industry would be the next.bomb.com
crash because it's on projected profits
it's not actually on
earn in fact the fracking industry loses
tremendous amounts of money so
uh and in a moment of instability
uh
then
you have already mainstreamed
islamophobia you've already mainstreamed
racism
attacks against poor people of color
uh and
the elites and this goes back to
yugoslavia well then use and or direct
that rage
towards
the vulnerable
and allow this incoherent
anger
to express itself through violence
as if these people are somehow
responsible and and you know the the uh
one of the things that disturbs me there
are two things that disturb me
uh particularly about trump one is
uh
the
uh poisoning of civil discourse
but also
that that characteristic which i write
about in the book of the permanent lie
which is different all politicians lie i
was a reporter they all lie there's no
exception obama lies clinton they all
lie
but
clinton
who
sold us nafta
uh and sold us nafta by promising that
it would mean
millions more good american jobs doesn't
continue
to tell us that nafta produced millions
of good american jobs
the permanent lie
which trump engages in and which
all demagogues all dictators all
totalitarian systems engage in
is
spouted regardless of reality reality
doesn't the [ __ ] you know we're just
watching how they fix the fake pictures
you know we had the park service edit
the pictures of the inauguration reality
doesn't make it doesn't and that's
extremely dangerous hannah aaron writes
about it in origins of totalitarianism
because it's what you see in front of
you is being denied
by the megaphone
and it creates a kind of schizophrenia
um and unfortunately
we are a society awash in fake news
which doesn't come out of moscow it
comes out of fox news it comes out of
breitbart it comes out of these i mean
the whole idea that fox news is now
considered a legitimate
journalistic enterprise
is staggering and frightening while
britain treats fox news as unreliable
and not a legitimate news of course it's
unreliable and it's a it's a piece it's
propaganda
well you're you're on rt which is a
russian news outlet yes
it could be taken as a conflict of
interest to say that you know it's not a
fake news machine
well i didn't say russia wasn't a fake
news machine all governments
i don't trust any government including
the russian government i mean i'm not
discriminating here
but
if you are an anti-capitalist and an
anti-imperialist critic
you have nowhere to go anymore
and so
uh i i know very well why rt allows my
show it's the same reason voice of
america put vaslav
on during the communist regime havel who
i was in the magic lantern theater every
night in prague during the velvet
revolution with havel was a socialist he
didn't support american imperialist
adventurism in vietnam or anywhere else
but he had nowhere else to go
and this is about the corruption
of our media platforms and in
particularly our
public television
if you went back to the 1960s on public
television you could see
malcolm x
gnome chomsky our greatest intellectual
who's
been
completely
uh blacklisted yes uh howard zinn james
baldwin
and now because they've slashed the
funding because pbs is dependent on
corporate donations like npr
it's
uh
uh the it's this constrictor of
acceptable opinion and of course you
know the koch brothers are big investors
in public broadcasting now of course
they're destroying the crown jewel of
american democracy which is called
public education
and
uh
that
constricture
has
left us without a vocabulary to
understand the class warfare that is
being waged against us
by a global corporate oligarchic and i
would argue criminal class
um and that's by intent
and so
the the elites understand that and this
is across the political spectrum there
nobody's buying their ideology of global
capitalism globalization neoliberalism
whatever you want to call it nobody's
buying it they're not buying it on the
right they're not buying on the left
and so the elites have re have gone
after over the last year
those critics
of
corporate capital is an imperialism who
already exist on the margins of the
internet and how have they done that
well
google facebook have imposed algorithms
that block those people out so i write a
column every monday for the website
truthdig run by robert shear one of the
great american journalists former editor
of ramparts and
uh and so
they have what they call impression so
if you'd gone to google and you typed
let's say imperialism and i had recently
written a story on imperialism or column
then it would be there with other now
it's not there and so we've watched at
truth dig alone
the referrals from imperialism uh
decline over the last 12 months from
seven hundred thousand to below two
hundred thousand
as they perfect the algorithms all of
the sites black agenda report
counter punch alternet which has lost 63
percent of its traffic world socialist
website 80 something percent of its
traffic
couple that with net the abolition of
net neutrality
and what they've done
is
uh further push
their critics
uh from
reaching the public
because
there they have no credibility left and
that loss of credibility is what led to
the insurgency in the democratic party
with sanders and it's what led to the
insurgency in the republican party with
trump
uh and the elites are kind of scrambling
you have to tip your hat vote to the
right because when they started being
blackballed from some of the websites
there was a strong unified response that
said you know you're shadow banning us
you're taking our right to speak it was
an impressive display of a unified
message whether it was accurate or not
they knew how to play that well there
was a unified message among those of us
on the left but we don't have any money
we don't have the most retrograde forces
of american capitalism
like the mercers bankrolling us
i have to poke at you a little bit
because i i looked at your section about
taking money from foundations and how
much that can endanger a message but
then in your acknowledgements you
thanked a foundation
well i did i thank the wallace action
fund
um which is about as left wing as you
can get number one and number two
probably about the only foundation that
would and they didn't they gave me
twenty five thousand dollars for a
research assistant we're not talking
about
what i wasn't wallowing in cash
you haven't cashed that soros check have
you
no source wouldn't give me money
uh let's talk about in fact you were
talking about the politicians and some
of the changes that have been coming
within the uh republican democratic
party folks in the audience are asking
what do we make of the rise of populism
and democratic socialism and you
actually say in the book that even
though there's some encouraging people
coming up they still will be compromised
because they're politicians
sure every politician's compromised i
mean that's the poison of power and
that's why movements are absolutely
vital
um and our movements the movements that
protected the american working class
have been destroyed in particular labor
unions
we we go back and look at the history of
the united states
and the united states was founded as a
closed system for male
uh
aristocratic slave-holding elites
and it has been a long fight since the
founding of our country
uh to open up democratic space and many
americans have paid with it paid for it
with their lives
we had hundreds of american workers
murdered
by gun thugs uh pinkertons baldwin felts
state militias state police like
pennsylvania who were called the
pennsylvania cossacks
um
and they
gave us uh the eight hour work day uh
they ended child labor the minimum wage
and
uh
we saw it in the struggle for civil
rights by african americans we saw it
with the suffrages um it's been a battle
and those movements
uh have quite consciously been targeted
and destroyed
um
we saw the powell memo in 1971 the
attack on the free enterprise system
where
the business interests
uh
reacted to what the political scientist
samuel huntington called the excess of
democracy
by
uh
making war
and by seizing control of the the press
the major political parties academia
uh i mean go into an economics
department in any uh
major university and find me a marxist
economist
i'm not a marxist actually but mark's
analysis of capital
is probably unsurpassed i don't buy a
solution which is i think utopian
uh
so
um
the wolf's radio program is very good
for economics yeah uh he's great
and
uh and and that analysis is almost
impossible to hear
uh certainly within the mainstream it is
impossible to hear right he's on pacific
and naturally yeah yeah
i've been on a show
um
let's talk about
trying to decide who it is that we can
partner with if we're going to save the
country if we're going to form alliances
uh you talked about the industrial areas
foundation which i had not heard of
before that's the old sololinsky
foundation
yes
and you're talking about people who come
together who may not otherwise merge on
thoughts they're sure you know um people
who come out of churches going with
people who are atheists but they all
recognize
a common need well that's the point and
and you know i i'm very
opposed to writing off as irredeemable
or deplorable
trump supporters
um i've been in you know in anderson
most of these old uaw workers they voted
for sanders but in the general election
they voted for trump
they weren't going to vote for clinton
not after nafta
impossible
and
maybe it comes from
my stock of a small town maine where
most of my relatives held
political views which were pretty
repugnant and drove around literally
with gun racks and but but it gave me a
window into their struggles
um and
the only way that we're going to advance
is to build coalitions
around
major economic issues i mean if you went
into a walmart and said i'm here to
organize i mean walmart the
uh
the
walmart family the waltons would never
allow you to even get in walmart i mean
there's the great union busting
corporation of america but if you could
get into a walmart and said we're here
to organize for 15
minimum wage
uh you would certainly have people of
various political persuasions who
would join you in that cause and i think
with that
we have to i i am very critical as you
know of the politics of multiculturalism
and uh identity politics divorced from
economic justice
uh and i think that you know there was i
think it was lord salisbury who said
there's no there's no
uh there's no permanent alliances only
permanent power
or certainly was how sololinsky worked
in chicago
we have to organize around issues
that affect the lives of working men and
women and the poor
uh and
uh you know who they voted for if they
voted uh
you know whatever i mean i think we have
a right to ask
them to respect everyone around them
but we're only going to build
significant change by making these
alliances not falling into the trap of
the class
divide by splitting the working classes
along
uh
uh racial
uh
you know or ideological lines that
serves the interests of of the oligarchs
doesn't that turn a little bit
problematic i'm thinking specifically of
when bernie sanders was on the trail and
there were some black lives matter
activists who got up at one of his
rallies and said you're not listening
we're being shot in the street you can
talk about giving us more jobs you can
talk about you know making more money
available to us right now we're being
killed and need to focus on that
and i think that when you put the
blanket of identity politics on that it
can sound
especially from a white guy
kind of decision i don't look at the
black lives matter movement as identity
politics at all
forgive me i misunderstood that i i i'm
talking about uh places like princeton
where i teach you because when you said
racism i thought you just well
no i'm i'm strong i write in the book
i'm a strong supporter of the last
chapter of the black lives movement
uh and in fact a matter of fact
interview activists from ferguson who i
admire immensely yes um no they're
responding to
police terror police murder
uh which happens in marginal communities
every single day in this country
and they have done so with immense
courage
uh and i will also add that i found
bernie sanders especially at the
beginning of his campaign tone deaf on
the issue of race and racial violence i
teach in a prison so i'm uh you know i i
see up close
uh what we have done to poor people of
color um the our system of mass
incarceration uh which is one of the
great human rights violations of the
industrial world 25 of the world's
prison population we are five percent of
the world's prison population 94 of
these people never even had a jury trial
this is about social control
it is about
uh
and and we saw it and clinton you know
go back to the 1994 omnibus crime bill
where he pumped 300
uh
uh million dollars into the prison
system uh expanded the prison population
from about seven hundred thousand to two
million
um
you you left
de-industrialized pockets uh there was
no hope for them to make a living within
the legal economy
um
they're not producing money for the
corporations on the streets of these
industrial wastelands but you lock them
in a cage and they can produce 50 or 60
thousand dollars a year for the prison
contractors for our mark which runs the
food service for global tell link which
uh has these horrible four to five times
uh what our phone rates are and and
that's makes me extremely
uh angry because for children the only
way they can have contact with their
parents incarcerated parents through the
telephone uh the privatization of uh
medical services uh um jpay money
transfer there it's a billion billions
in terms of
predatory activity and dostoyevsky says
if you want to understand the heart of a
society
look in their prisons look what they do
to the most vulnerable
and now we have almost a million
prisoners who work for for-profit
corporations and there are cities and
counties that tell prisons if you build
here we'll keep the cages full yeah well
they do they and they do keep and their
lobbyists pass laws uh to keep
recidivism rates over 60 percent
um you know people say the system
doesn't work that's wrong the system
works exactly the way it's designed to
work and we just
have had uh this uh prison
work stoppage commissary boycott even
hunger strikes within the system because
they fully understand uh that the only
way to end slavery and we're talking
about states like georgia where people
work 40 hours a week for nothing or they
work for 20 cents an hour
is to stop being a slave because if you
if you paid the minimum wage within
prisons
and you don't have to under the 13th
amendment
the prison system would not be
sustainable it would just be
economically too costly to sustain so
you look at marginal communities you've
stripped people of their rights you
engage in police terror
and they replicate the condition of the
stateless which hannah erin writes about
and she said the danger is that when you
have a
a section of your society who can be
stripped of their rights in essence
rights become privileges then
in a moment of unrest or instability you
have both a legal and a physical
mechanism by which everyone can be
stripped of their rights and so
uh
i mean just from a kind of human point
of view uh i'm incensed at what we do to
the poor and in particular poor people
of color but also as somebody who has
covered disintegrating societies
uh i'm frightened uh by the
normalization
including lethal police force i mean an
average of 3.3 americans almost all of
whom are unarmed are murdered by police
in the streets of our city every day
and if you think
it won't affect us then you don't know
anything about history right
you quote malcolm x i found this to be a
very interesting quote don't run around
trying to make friends with someone
who's depriving you of your rights
they're not your friends no they're your
enemies treat them like that fight them
and you'll get your freedom after you
get your freedom your enemy will respect
you i say that with no hate i don't have
hate in me i don't have any hate i've
got some sense i'm not going to let
anyone who hates me tell me to love him
reason that's particularly intriguing is
we talk about
the corporate
the elite the people who have all the
power and all the money
benefiting when we fight amongst
ourselves when the lower classes fight
amongst themselves
and it's easy to look at the people who
want to be on abortion who are doing the
preppers and anticipate that you know
they're going to have to shoot everyone
it's easy to look at them and say that's
the person who hates me that's the
person who i don't want to be friends
with so make that distinction for us
with malcolm x's quote well malcolm
understood the nature of power
and uh
you know i do come out of
a divinity school background
and power is the problem
and so
uh when people wield power
to carry out acts of radical evil
when they seek to extinguish life and
they are
through the fossil fuel industry seeking
to extinguish life for all of us and our
children
then um
one has to react exactly the way malcolm
pointed out
um
but
i i admire malcolm x quite a bit and uh
i i think malcolm was uh like martin
luther king
one of our great prophets
uh and uh
um
i mean malcolm wrote about white
southerners
and he actually had a great quote where
he said uh you know i'd rather have a
white southerner call me the n-word than
deal with a white liberal
um
a malcolm got power completely as did
king you know and when king
moved on at the end of the civil rights
movement towards economic justice
those white liberals walked out on him
he was all alone
uh because yes they could handle
desegregation
but as king and malcolm understood there
would never be racial justice in this
country
until there was economic justice
which
means reparations
um and the inability on the part of the
white ruling elites
to face
the
monstrous
crime against humanity
that they carried out in order to enrich
this country both against native
americans and african-americans
has
created
the mythical version of america and
american virtues and american innocence
that is embodied in
the face of donald trump
i want to go back to the fact that so
many of our audience members are asking
about how you talk to people with whom
you have opposing views and i'm thinking
about the person that you interviewed in
the book whose view of i can imagine
what he'd say about reparations but
the the way that black people portray
how many people get attacked that
there's actually more black on white
crime um
that people who didn't own slaves or
slaves were happy slaves were sad when
their masters died and i'm so that was
dylan roof but
but it's an attitude that's out there i
mean this is how would you subtracting
dylann roof how would you talk to
someone
when you're trying to explain for
example reparations where you're trying
to talk about the generational loss with
something well you you can't speak to
people who are
not uh engaged in the real world
i spent two years writing a book on the
christian right called american fascists
the christian right
and the war on american i didn't
actually use the word fascist lightly i
look at them as christian heretics they
have fused the iconography and
language of the christian religion uh
with uh the iconography and language of
the state which is fascism for me
um they are not about love they are
about hate um they are biblical
they are selective literalists they
don't actually know the bible i mean
when i was with them i was always up
front about where i came from and as
soon as they realized that i grew up in
the church my father was a presbyterian
minister and i was a graduate of harvard
they never wanted to talk about the
bible with me they were too frightened
uh because they only know what they were
fed that buttressed
their peculiar ideology
so you're never going to argue someone
like that out of creationism it isn't
going to happen and the reason is
because the real world the world out
there the world uh where magic jesus
wasn't watching out for them
almost destroyed them and the stories in
that book
are also heartbreaking
uh and they and i was moved by them so
your substance abuse domestic abuse
sexual abuse
uh unemployment evictions i mean their
lives were just
ripped apart
by the disintegration of
their communities their families
and the economic
uh
blockages that prevented them from uh
reaching their hopes and aspirations
and i came at the end of that book to
the conclusion that we're not going
we're not going to argue them out of any
of that
um
the only way to blunt that movement
which i wrote that book 10 years ago
which has now gotten worse because these
christian fascists are rapidly filling
the ideological vacuum around donald
trump
is to reintegrate them into the economy
and so you ask how to speak to them i
sat for hours
and interviewed them about their lives
about what they suffered about what they
endured about and and those stories
engendered in me a very real and
legitimate empathy and they felt it and
the other thing is i never
ever and this comes out of being a
reporter for many years
i i'm always completely honest
with the people i interview i never
pretend to be something i'm not
i never use a pseudonym
and
when i did the christian right they knew
i came out of the liberal church they
knew i went to harvard divinity school
and i think that when you have that kind
of honesty coupled with the capacity for
empathy
you can actually have
meaningful conversations
uh and what was interesting is that
there were people in that book on the
christian right
whose world view was almost
diametrically opposed to mine
but
who who
who afterwards contacted me because i
had told their stories with compassion
and respect
and so i think that when you ask how we
speak to them we speak to them about
their suffering
and we empathize with that suffering and
that is the start of a relationship and
we grasp that they have retreated into a
form of magical thinking out of despair
and that trying to dissuade them of that
magical thinking rips down the last
protective cover they have and so
um
i didn't pretend that i believed in
creationism and yet i didn't try and
argue them out of the idea that in six
days god created all living beings
including t-rex who was in the garden of
eden with adam and eve which you know
they believe i mean and if you go to the
creationist museum in peterborough
kentucky they have a t-rex with a saddle
on it
and
you know it's funny in here but when
you're sitting there with 40 people and
believe it it's not funny it's chilling
and the guide is saying well i know you
all wonder why t-rex
had such big teeth it's because adam and
eve used t-rex to open the coconuts
but that shows you how how uh how
they've disengaged with
the real world and
that is anthropologists call it crisis
cults you saw with a ghost dance in 1890
that is a characteristic of every
society none of us are immune from it
but it is a symptom of a society in deep
deep distress
i didn't realize until i read your book
that there are silicon valley preppers
but even at the highest
people preparing for the year let's not
get started on silicon valley
the great great great enabler of the
security and surveillance state
[Laughter]
actually we're too short on the time but
we promised we would get into some of
your last ch
enjoyed this from one of the audience
members okay i haven't read the last
chapter of the book what can be done
okay we're getting into that talk about
burdock house
so
i
we have to regain communities that have
been destroyed
to pit power against power we have to
build alternative systems that sever us
from the tentacles of corporate power um
we have to turn off our electronic
hallucinations
um
you know if you are sitting alone in
your room furiously writing on your
computer
screen
you know some diatribe against
state authority you are
doing just what the state wants which is
sitting alone in your room in front of a
computer screen
we have to build relationships the only
way relationships can be built and
that's face to face
um
the fact that i had real relationships
with members of the christian not the
leaders who are you know the these
people who run these mega churches they
they are
they're all like trump back people say
how can the christian right
you know a lie with trump and that gives
the christian right a morality it
doesn't have these mega church pastors i
mean even in terms of sexual
proclivities they're doing things trump
never dreamed of uh
so and they're making money off of
people's despair which is how trump made
his money so
uh they're they're complete they're
they're two p's in a pod they're the
same they're they're
um
but the fact that i could have
relationships and what we have to build
those relationships and that comes with
listening
it comes with empathy
um that doesn't mean that
you know
you know i was quite upfront if they
made a particular comment about a racial
group or homosexuals i i didn't let it
pass
but it doesn't mean you can't have if we
don't rebuild those relationships and if
we don't rebuild structures to pit power
against power
then in the next financial crash which
is coming
um
and and moment of instability
um they will play us
in a very frightening way i mean trump
is not a product of just our decayed
political system
boris johnson orbon and hungary it's
happening throughout the industrialized
world where the wreckage of
neoliberalism
has destroyed
has concentrated wealth in the hands of
the oligarchic class and destroyed
democratic institutions and we are
watching betsy devos destroy
public education and why
because the department of education
spends 63
uh
billion dollars a year on education and
the hedge funds want it
and they're going to get it
i mean the pillage won't stop until we
make them stop
burdock house burdock house is an
example of that former cap kids in their
20s former catholic workers they buy an
old warehouse for twenty five thousand
dollars they recon
recondition it refurbish it to have
rooms uh in the backyard they hold it
was i found it quite moving uh people
these kids trapped in these
low-wage menial
uh you know deadening jobs
uh come and read poetry one of the guys
i interviewed quite a talented blues
musician was playing blues and and look
that we have to get in touch with those
non-rational forces that the
technological society seeks to diminish
or extinguish
what are those forces beauty
truth
grief
a search for meaning the struggle with
our own mortality
this is what makes a complete human
being and it's why the technocratic
state makes war on the humanities and
culture
and and it you know the buddhists say
you can memorize as many sutras as you
want it will never make you wise and we
have to recover wisdom
and the capacity for transcendence
the understanding that there are human
lives and
systems of life
that have an intrinsic value beyond a
monetary value
and that and in is as polyani says that
are sacred and and the society that the
consumer society the technocratic
society
at its core
has made war on the sacred and our only
hope is to recover it
um
because it it it gives us a sense of
self our place in the universe and most
importantly it connects us
and and and that atomization that
alienation that enemy that isolation
is not only deadening to our souls
and thrusting us into despair but as an
effective political technique to keep us
captive
last question the messiness of democracy
with all its paralysis and reverses
keeps revolution
alive and vibrant
you want to expound on that
sure because uh this is
uh karl popper's understanding that an
open society you have mechanisms by
which piecemeal and incremental reform
is possible
the new deal you have the collapse of
capitalism roosevelt says
look if the private sector can't create
jobs the government has to create jobs
he created 12 million jobs social
security
and
when that capacity for
um
change
is
becomes calcified as it has become in
our corporate state
then
uh
you you redirect when you redirect all
of the the wealth and the systems of
power to a cabal in this case a
corporate cabal
you leave behind
the majority of your population
to
fester
and to
express in very self-destructive ways
the pathologies that i write about in
this book
and
you know what i fear
is that this time around when capitalism
goes down
we won't have the progressive party the
old cio and independent press
uh labor unions you know wobblies we
won't have any of that
and you know in the 1930s europe went
one way italy and germany spain and we
went another
uh and
and i i just see especially with the
rhetoric
uh coming out of the white house and the
rise of these trump minimes and places
like florida
uh you know
and the transformation of the republican
party into a kind of uh party or built
around a personality cult
um
i
uh i worry that we will swing we have
the potential to swing
to a kind of
corporate-backed
christianized
fascism
on that hopeful note
[Laughter]
thank you thank you very much
it's been such a pleasure thank you
thank you for that and if you have your
books and would like to have them signed
they're going to be signed right back
that away by the staff sign so if you'll
uh give chris just a moment for andrew
to get him over to that table where
you'll be signed and then take your
place in line and to get your book
signed thank you so much for coming
[Applause]
uh